[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so yesterday was Michael
Bloomberg's first debate as a Democratic
presidential candidate he finally got
the polling support that he needed in
order to get into a debate now that of
course the DNC has eliminated that
individual donor requirement as a
prerequisite for getting into the
debates and Michael Bloomberg was eaten
alive I mean just absolutely annihilated
in what could be a campaign ending
debate I don't know it might not be and
we're gonna talk about that a little bit
later depends on how many people watched
the debate it depends how many people
are sort of staking their support on
Michael Bloomberg based on something
like debate performance rather than for
other reasons we'll get to that
we were wondering will it be the
centrists attacking Bloomberg because he
is more of a direct threat to them would
it be the progressives Bernie and Warren
trying to take advantage of having a
turbo billionaire on the stage to talk
about how radically different their
policies are and the answer was yes yes
to all of it yes to all of the above
everybody attacked Bloomberg centrists
in one way the progressives in another
way and I'm gonna show you some of those
moments now before we do this if you had
pulled me aside yesterday five minutes
before the debate and said to me David
if you had to guess do you think
Elizabeth Warren will mention
horse-faced lesbians in the first twenty
seconds of the debate later in the
debate or not at all I probably would
have said I don't expect Elizabeth
Warren to mention horse-faced lesbians
and I would have been wrong within the
first 20 seconds at her first
opportunity to talk Elizabeth Warren
going right in on Michael Bloomberg with
alleged comments that he's made about
women take a look for another four years
and we can't stand that so why I'd like
to talk about who were running against
a billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg Democrats are not
going to win just immediately setting
the tone for what was going to be a
night of slamming Michael Bloomberg
without Bloomberg defending himself
particularly well and he was taking hits
left and right it was non-stop the worst
moment for Bloomberg was when Elizabeth
Warren started pressing him about
non-disclosure agreements with former
employees related to sexual harassment
most of which we believe I mean we don't
know because there nd aid but we believe
most of it was between other employees
in other words it was at Bloomberg's
company but didn't involve Bloomberg
although eventually Bloomberg talks
about you know jokes I told that people
may not have liked and Bloomberg was not
well prepared for this really really
brutal and again Elizabeth Warren just
really destroying him senator Warren
even critical here Bloomberg on this
issue yes I have and I hope you've heard
what his defense was I've been nice to
some women
the mayor has to stand on his record and
what we need to know is exactly what's
lurking out there he has gotten some
number of women dozens who knows to sign
non-disclosure agreements both for
sexual harassment and for gender
discrimination in the workplace so mr.
mayor are you willing to release all of
those women from those non-disclosure
agreements so we can hear their side of
the story
we have a very few non-disclosure
agreements how many I may finish how
many is there none of them accuse me of
doing anything other than maybe they
didn't like a joke I told and let me
just put and let me play so this is
already terrible I did nothing other
than maybe somebody didn't like a joke I
told that's terrible that's it I
couldn't think of a worse way to try to
explain what happened
typically jokes don't lead to pay offs
and non-disclosure agreements it's
already bad for Michael Bloomberg but
let's continue maybe they didn't like a
joke I told and let me just put and let
me put these are the agreements between
two parties that wanted to keep it quiet
and that's up to them they sign those
agreements and will live with it so wait
when you say I just want to be clear
some is how many and and when you and
when you say they signed them and they
wanted them if they wish now to speak
out and tell their side of the story
about what it is they allege that's now
okay with you you're releasing them on
television tonight senator cent of the
company and somebody else in this case
the man or a woman or could be but more
than that they decided when they made an
agreement that they wanted to keep it
quiet for everybody's interest they sign
the agreements and that's what we're
going to no the question is bound by
being muzzled by you and you could
release them from that immediately but
does understand this is not just a
question of the mayor's character so
just taking shot after shot and what we
learned yesterday was that Michael
Bloomberg did not make his billions
winning any debates that's for very sure
a very good analysis of what happened by
brand-new CNN political commentator
Andrew yang about Bloomberg's failure
here is Andrew Yang's take on it yeah
and you know the field the best you know
what it's like on that stage what was
the read I think three things happened
to Mike tonight
number one he just found out he'd make
the debate yesterday there were two
times when I wasn't sure
I was going to make the debate and my
team got me together to prepare and
you're really not sure if you're
preparing because you're like I'm not
sure if I'm gonna be in this debate so
Mike even though he was I'm sure getting
coached and prepared he was like I don't
know if I'm gonna be in this debate and
so I don't think he was coached hard
enough number two he was clearly
instructed to keep his cool no matter
what but that ended up presenting as
being lethargic and uninterested for a
big chunk of the debate and the third
most telling thing is that if I'm his
team you know he's gonna get a stop in
the first question like a gender
discrimination or mistreatment question
so you coach him and you have him give
you 60 75 second answers over and over
again until he can do it in his sleep
and the fact that he did not have those
answers at his fingertips lets me know
categorically he was not properly
prepared for me now I could go on with
the Bloomberg stuff but it's all this
bad before we move on if you want to say
what good moments did Bloomberg have I
think his best moments were at one point
there there was a debate about whether
it should be mandatory that employees be
given 20% ownership of the companies
where they work and Bloomberg said guys
this isn't going to happen and it helps
Trump that we're even talking about this
and I tend to agree with him there we
want to democratize the workplace there
are countless ways to do it work or
representation on boards tying you know
the the multiple of the CEO wage there's
all these different things we can do a
law that mandates 20% ownership is
turned over to employees it's just not
happening anytime soon and making it a
subject of debate pushes people away
from any Democrat I believe and here is
Michael Bloomberg making that point so
they can have some say over what happens
to their lives
senator Sanders is proposing absolutely
not I can't think of a ways that would
make it easier for Donald Trump to get
re-elected and listening to this
conversation
ridiculous we're not gonna throw out
capitalism
we tried that other countries tried that
was called communism and it just didn't
work that has not only support from then
at another point Michael Bloomberg also
talking about as he mentions there the
the communism thing that's a total red
herring and it doesn't make any sense to
mention that we're not talking about
communism here
Bloomberg is right that a debate about
forcing companies to give 20% of their
ownership away is a non-starter right
now the communism comment is just dumb
one other moment that was sort of okay
for Bloomberg although it ended up
falling flat was bringing up this tired
old thing about Bernie's three houses in
the country happens to be a millionaire
with three houses what'd I miss here
well you Lister I work in Washington
house watch the first problem live in
Burlington house to that's good and like
thousands of other for Martha's I do I
have a summer camp to get me for that
where is your home which tax which tax
haven New York New York City thank you
very much so I don't know I mean maybe
by some standard it was okay for
Bloomberg but it was really really bad
overall the one thing that Bernie that
Bloomberg's presence did do was
energized just about everybody on the
stage even Joe Biden was fired up in the
first part of the debate Warren had
higher energy if Biden had had
yesterday's level of energy throughout
the debates he might not have tanked his
polling the way that it has the other
really weird dynamic was mayor Pete
versus Amy Klobuchar getting into some
very odd exchanges including Pete
hammering her about forgetting the
president of Mexico's name really going
hard on that and I said that I made an
error I think having a president that
maybe is humble and is able to admit
that here and there maybe wouldn't be a
bad thing
it's too trivial I actually didn't know
how many members were in the the Knesset
so yeah but you're staking your
candidacy on your Washington experience
you're on the committee that oversees
border security you're on the committee
that does trade you're literally in a
part of the committee that's overseeing
these things and we're not able to speak
to literally the first thing about the
politics of the country to ourselves are
you trying to say that I'm dumb are you
mocking me here Pete I made an error
people sometimes forget names I am the
one that has number one has the
experience based on passing over 1 if I
could respond this was a pretty big
validation he's basically saying that I
don't have the experience to be
President of the United States I have
passed over 100 bills as a lead Democrat
since being in the US Senate I am the
one not you that has won statewide in
congressional district after
congressional district and I will say
when you tried in Indiana Pete to what
run what happened to you you lost by
over 20 points to someone who later lost
to my friend Joe Donnelly so don't tell
me about experience what unites us here
is we want to win I genuinely don't know
who that was good or bad for because it
was also weird and Pete just continuing
to go after her on this issue and I
think we should put a proven winner in
charge of the ticket there's no race for
president if winning the race for Senate
in Minnesota translated directly to
becoming president I would have grown up
under the presidency of Walter Mondale
this is different and the reason that I
think we need to talk about Washington
experience is that we should ask what
that experience has led to experiences
and certainly tenure is not always the
same thing as judgment we're going to
talk about votes in the Senate in
Washington let's talk about
a lot of talking over each other there
and that was another unfortunate theme
of the night candidates and moderators
constantly talking over each other many
of the candidates being cut short in
their answers one of the moderators
Chuck Todd almost constantly with a
running soundtrack of it yeah yeah and
okay okay over the candidates answers
extremely extremely annoying Bernie had
a lot of good moments for example this
one defending workers again in the face
of Bloomberg the target for the night is
your policy thank it is my policy and
I'm very proud of that policy all right
what we need to do to deal with this
protest level of income and wealth
inequality is make sure that those
people who are working you know one mr.
Bloomberg wasn't you who made all that
money maybe your workers played some
role in that as well
those workers are able to share the
benefits also when we have so many
people go to work every day and they
feel not good about their jobs they feel
like cogs in a machine I want workers to
be able to sit on corporate boards as
well so they can have some say over what
happens to their lives
another strong Bernie moment calling out
mayor Pete in sort of clearer more
direct terms this time about his
billionaire or billionaire donors Pete
visibly sweating during this moment when
you see the close-up of Pete he's
sweating badly if speaking to the needs
and the pain of a long-neglected working
class is polarizing I think you got the
wrong word what we are trying finally to
do is to give a voice to people who
after 45 years of work are not making a
nickel more than they did 45 years ago
we are giving a voice for people who are
say we are stricter diet a billionaires
like mr. Bloomberg's seeing huge
expansions of their wealth while a half
a million people sleep out on the street
tonight and that's all what we are
saying Pete is maybe it's the time for
the working class of this country to
have a little bit of power in Washington
rather than your billionaire campaign
contributors very very strong Bernie
throughout I would probably say Bernie
and Warren were the strongest last night
with Joe Biden close behind just showing
more energy than he has in recent times
Pete and Amy sort of going after each
other on weird things and then Bloomberg
really the loser of the night so if you
say to me who is the in the net who's
the biggest winner last night I actually
believe it's Donald Trump
Donald Trump net benefited the most from
last night's debate because Bloomberg
completely self destructed and we'll see
what this does to his campaign the other
candidates got shots in at Bloomberg but
otherwise I don't believe the needle
will be greatly moved for anybody else
because we're so far into this thing and
the only new presence on the stage
was Michael Bloomberg and overall the
what will be portrayed as infighting by
the right even though it was making very
clear the different types of choices
that are available I think in the net
Trump comes away with a slight benefit
from last night's debates just my
opinion you can disagree with me and we
can all be reasonable respectful people
on that issue did a poll on my Twitter
about 4,000 of you voted the question
was how does tonight's debate affect
Bloomberg's polling a plurality nearly
40% said Bloomberg loses eight or more
points as a result of last night's
performance I don't think it's actually
that bad but I do think Bloomberg loses
a bit maybe has to spend another hundred
million to gain it back
I did not expect Bloomberg to get as
annihilated as he did last night and one
other thought that I had about last
night's debate last night's debate was
by far the most entertaining debate of
the primary but we also probably heard
the least about policy from the
candidates detailed policy it was a lot
of attacks on Bloomberg Pete and Amy
arguing about experience and how bad it
is not to know the name of the President
of Mexico you had a lot of talking point
attacks that's probably in some way
emblematic of our politics and media
today sadly the most entertaining to
watch debate whose ratings may have been
very very good had the least substantive
policy discussion of any recent debate I
can remember certainly ideological
differences and draw lines in the sand
were drawn but maybe in some way this is
part of the problem that we're having in
the discourse in the United States I
guess the major thing we learned of new
information is Michael Bloomberg is not
a good debater let me know your thoughts
let me know what you expect to be the
implications and repercussions to last
night's debate I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman we'll take a quick break and be
back
or the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are jenny Audet and judy Litzy
thanks to Jenny and Judy really
appreciate your support and the support
of everybody who's joined recently I
also want to say a quick thank you but a
very sincere one to Deanna McGowan
Deanna's today's longtime sustaining
member of the day Deanna's been with us
almost five years
grab a membership at join pakman.com a
lot of interesting discussions on the
David Pakman show
reddit which you can find at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT sumner
breeze posted vote blue no matter who
except for racist New York billionaire
mayors who stopped in frisk minorities
senile dementia patients who were creepy
to women and want to cut Social Security
CIA agents who fix bread prices lie
about supporting single-payer health
care and are funded by billionaires and
anyway the point is we get to so who do
we have left folks a viewer who clearly
is concerned that I guess litmus tests
being applied in the Democratic primary
ignoring that maybe all of these folks
are better than Trump will lead to a
Trump reelection an interesting post
although I'm not a hundred percent sure
of the message as I've said before if
the candidate is better than Trump I
will vote for the candidate use their
music writer posted will a contested
convention screw over Bernie Sanders
again saying
with so many contenders fighting for
delegates it's looking increasingly
likely that no one candidate will
receive a plurality of the delegates I
think they mean a majority if Bernie
ultimately wins the most delegates but
falls short of the 51% requirement does
this mean the DNC super-delegates will
likely be given the chance to flock to
one of the establishment friendly
candidates I'm wondering if a contested
convention pretty much means we are
screwed all over again
the answer is probable
yes but it's still early we've had two
primaries we've got a third one coming
soon a fourth one then Super Tuesday it
is true that the most likely scenario
right now and we'll get into this in
more detail according to 538 is a
situation where no one gets 50% plus one
that doesn't necessarily lead to a
contested convention with a second round
of voting because there can be
negotiations that happen between the
last primary and the first boat where
one candidate will direct their
delegates to support somebody else but
yes if it goes to a second round that is
the most likely scenario lastly a post
on the reddit that says yoy is tulsi
still here for some no shot candidates I
get their reasons steyr has a lot of
money Clos Bashar had good results in
New Hampshire Warren is somewhat viable
but not for long
but Tulsi there are more reasons to stay
in than winning I get that media
attention name recognition but why stay
in when you are only losing you will be
known as a loser and progressives will
see you as someone taking votes away
from Bernie listen anybody who wants to
run for president should run anybody who
wants to stay in should stay in I
actually don't really worry much about
Tulsi getting out at this point like
she's literally polling zero delegates
she has a path to zero delegates she's
not on the debate stage I don't know
that she's running ads I don't see or
hear anything about Tulsi except people
tweeting me so I'm not even really
worried about what Tulsi does
join the discussion at david pakman.com
slash read it okay this is serious and
this relates to last night's debate we
already talked about the debate
performance we talked about Mike
Bloomberg getting eaten alive clearly
didn't make his billions debating that's
for sure we talked about the very clear
divisions between the progressives and
the centrist during last night's debate
but we have to talk about our democracy
when we talk about our system of
democracy in the United States we will
often point out the flaws of the
electoral college system where
Republican presidents have frequently
lost the popular vote more people voted
for their opponent but yet they became
President of the United States 2016 and
on
Trump is an example this happened with
George W Bush we've talked about this
before a similar dynamic exists in the
Democratic nomination process wherein
you can have a plurality of pledged
delegates going into the Democratic
National Convention more delegates than
anybody else but you can end up not
being the nominee when super-delegates
typically party insiders and elected
officials get to vote on this time in
the second round of DNC voting this came
up at last night's debate there was one
person on the stage who said I believe
that whoever has the most delegates
should be the nominee that was Bernie
Sanders every other candidate said we
should follow the system we should
follow the rules of the DNC take a look
at this video and I want to ask all of
you this simple question there's a very
good chance of none of you we're gonna
have enough delegates to the Democratic
National Convention that clinch this
nomination okay if that happens I want
all of your opinions on this should the
person with the most delegates at the
end of this primary season be the
nominee even if they are short of a
majority senator Sanders I let you go
last year because I know your view on
this so instead I will start with you
Mayor Bloomberg whatever the rules the
Democratic Party are they should be
followed and if they have a process
which I believe they do
everybody can Dickens you want the
convention to work as well yes senator
Horne convention working as well means
that people have the delegates that are
pledged to them and they keep those
delegates okay yes or no leading person
with the delegates should they be the
nominee or not no let the process work
its way out Mayor Budaj not necessarily
not to the senator klobuchar let the
process work
senator Sanders well the process
includes 500 super-delegates on the
second ballot so I think that the will
of the people
yes thank you guys
this is not a trivial issue not only
because it goes to the core of what does
it mean to reflect the will of the
people but this is not a trivial issue
because this is increasingly likely to
be the scenario we already know that if
Bernie keeps getting 25 or 30 percent of
the vote in primaries he likely will not
have 50% of the delegates the way the
math works you can get 50% of the
delegates without 50% of the vote we did
this yesterday if you are in the 35 to
38 range percent of the vote depending
on how many viable candidates there are
that is enough to get 50% of the
delegates but if Bernie stays around 28
to 31 it's very likely he won't get 1991
delegates case in point the
fivethirtyeight.com
estimate right now says that the most
likely scenario is one in which nobody
gets to 50% plus one of the delegates
there's a 40% probability of that Bernie
getting 50% plus one has a 37%
probability no other scenario gets past
11% now the DNC increasingly knows this
the candidates on the stage increasingly
know this and this is the strategy to
deny Bernie the nomination so what every
candidate on that stage is saying is I
don't think that if you enter the
convention with the most delegates you
should be the nominee they are saying no
matter who gets the most delegates
super-delegates should have their say
and the DNC's completely flawed process
is what gets to decide and by the way
what they're also sort of saying is and
I hope you'll pick me when that time
comes Bernie is saying the will of the
people should determine who the nominee
is it's very simple nobody else is
saying that on the stage and what this
certainly reveals is that the candidates
themselves are all but conceding Bernie
will get the most delegates but it's a
bold-faced attempt to try to sort of
cross their fingers say I stand by the
system I'm in line and hope that the DNC
will pick them to be the nominees when
Bernie fails to get to
thousand nine hundred and ninety-one
delegates now I've been consistent on
this from day one this is not about any
individual candidates policy I don't
think we should have an electoral
college system nationally and I don't
think we should have a delegate system
for the nomination that includes
super-delegates at any point in time now
at the national level we can get around
the electoral college without a big
constitutional amendment through
something called the national popular
vote interstate compact and what that
the way that works is if enough states
say we will give our electors to whoever
wins the popular vote if enough states
such that their total number of
electoral votes totals 270 without
changing the Constitution you have a de
facto national popular vote we know the
path to that nationally for the DNC
system to change the DNC needs to agree
to change it why would they do that when
this is how they retain some degree of
control over who the nominee is
regardless of the will of the people
it's an uphill battle for sure this was
a very telling moment from last night's
debate and one that without a doubt is
going to be consequential in terms of
who ultimately is the nominee and
something we're going to be watching
very closely in terms of numbers as the
delegates start to be apportioned on the
basis of voting let's take a quick break
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pack
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to welcome to the
program today EJ Dionne who is a
columnist for The Washington Post senior
fellow at the Brookings Institution and
also author of Code Red
how progressives and moderates can unite
to save our country so I guess that the
first question is unite to save the
country from who or what right right and
in the first instance it's obviously
trunk trumpism the attack on the rule of
law that we've been seeing a lot very
recently but all through the
administration to turn away from
democracy but it's also to save the
country from a radicalized right and
radicalized Republican Party the book is
obviously a very anti-trump book but it
is also very critical of a radical right
that really now dominates the Republican
Party and is driven out all vestiges of
both moderation and back in the day even
some liberalism progressivism that
existed inside the Republican Party and
so I argue that in this circumstance
progressives and moderates and we could
argue about the term moderate I'm
careful in the book to say I know
moderate itself is a vexed term but we
could say the center left and left as
well that they have far more in common
with each other at this moment then they
then they have with anyone on the other
side their differences are much smaller
than their differences with the other
side and a subsidiary argument is that
one of the reasons arguments inside the
Democratic Party can get so fierce is
that people who are on the progressive
side have lost sort
sensible interlocutor in the Republican
Party that almost all the major
conversations about solving public
problems take place inside the
Democratic Party so Obamacare was a
program that was built in part on ideas
developed by the Heritage Foundation and
by Mitt Romney and Massachusetts and
this was cast as somehow socialist by
the other side and so Democrats are now
having the argument that might in
another era have taken place across
party lines you expand on Obamacare or
do you go to single-payer that's the
kind of argument I make in the book but
I argue to get past this moment both of
the truck moment end of a radicalized
conservatism progressives and moderates
need to be allied because that's the
only way out of this this morass we're
in so does that presume this idea of
vote for the Democratic nominee no
matter who they are like is that a
related idea to what you are arguing
right I think in this circumstance there
is pretty much no alternative to that
and it's obvious that there are you know
a lot of Democrats especially after last
night who might have second thoughts
about voting for Michael Bloomberg the
robot is going to be my exact question
know it because you know and I think
that that will be more difficult I mean
I think it was difficult going into that
debate I think it's even more difficult
coming out of that debate similarly
there are people on the right end if you
will of this broad coalition I'm
describing who have some questions about
Bernie Sanders at this moment I think
the Bloomberg question will be the
harder question for an awful lot of
people both on the left and you know
after the demolition job that Elizabeth
Warren did particularly among
progressive women yeah and you know I've
said I'm not supporting Bloomberg in the
primary but if it's November 3rd and
it's Bloomberg versus Trump I'm voting
for Bloomberg and I've pointed out I
think
on Supreme Court justice selections
Bloomberg will make far better choices
than what Trump has evidenced he would
do I've listed a few things and it
doesn't mean I'm any great fan of him
but I know a lot of people in my
audience don't feel that way at all and
might my sort of follow-on question to
this is I believe in and support what we
would call a vigorous debate during the
primary about which ideas should reign
supreme so to speak but I wonder is
there a point at which it becomes
self-destructive in the eventual general
election yeah I am worried about that I
may have noticed I have a column up
today where and this was here I wrote
most of it before the debate that the
kind of demolition-derby that Democrats
are having is leading to they're
ignoring right on that stage last night
what is going on outside it was really
striking how little Trump himself was
mentioned we are really at a potential
constitutional crisis here
with what's going on inside the Justice
Department what has gone on with Roger
stone how all these cases are being
cherry picked on Ukraine and Russia
bye-bye bar these are very disturbing
things it did disturb me that Democrats
were spending so much time sort of
settling their own differences that they
didn't even get to hey we're all here
because we need to put a stop to this
you know on your Bloomberg point I think
you're correct that you know Court
appointments on what his budgets would
look like even his tax program is far
more progressive than anything
Republicans had to offer and his support
for both the climate movements and
especially the gun movements is a real
thing he's made a huge difference there
I think that what we saw last night will
raise questions not only on the left but
a lot of other people saying is this AG
is he actually the strongest candidate
to put against Trump I think that was
the argument he needed to make and
clearly last night on that front was a
fail no certainly if his making billions
depended on winning debates I don't know
that he would be nearly nearly as
wealthy as as he is was was my readin
yeah so now and in terms of when we've
seen in the past elections that are
heavily based around defeating the
incumbent so John Kerry in 2004 against
George W Bush strikes me as one of those
there is often the argument made that
you've really got to be voting for
something as opposed to trying to remove
the incumbent that it often doesn't go
well when the main message is remove the
incumbent so do you agree with that and
is that maybe something that tempers the
problem of Trump not being mentioned
that much yesterday which in a way I
found refreshing to just hear the
candidates talk about something other
than Trump right well I think there are
two sides to this and maybe we can take
Ronald Reagan as the example one of my
arguments in the book by the way is that
a key reason why there has been a
resurgence of democratic socialism in
the u.s. which by the way has a long
American tradition as I point out in the
book Eugene Debs got 6% of the boat
there were actually 1,200 local elected
officials who were socialists back in
that election the reason why you've had
a revival of democratic socialism is a
reaction to the dominance of our public
conversation by the Reagan economic
consensus and so the rise of democratic
socialism is a reaction against that but
what did Reagan do to create that long
hegemony that long period of
conservative dominance I think there
were two sides of it I think running
against an incumbent who's unpopular is
actually a helpful thing politically
Jimmy Carter was unpopular and I argue
in the book for what I call the power of
negative thinking that when you looked
at what Ronald Reagan built his program
on it started out as a series of
negatives anti-tax anti-communist
anti-government I think what pulls
together this coalition are a similar
set of an ties obviously anti-trump
and all the things that represents you
know a the oppression of immigrants and
refugees a your corporate corruption
cast as populism a host disrespect for
within a whole series of things but also
a backlash against a Republican Party
that is simply given up on public
problem solving on using government to
address inequality to provide health
insurance a whole series of areas where
they propose simply retreating cutting
taxes relying entirely on the public
sector but out of that negative comes a
series of positives and if I can just
pick three quick issues that are really
burning issues that raise real
coalition-building possibilities right
now the entire Democratic Party the
entire spectrum from Saturday left now
wants to provide affordable good health
insurance to every American that's not
even debated anymore the debate is over
whether we do it through a public option
and building on Obamacare or go directly
up to single-payer lord I do not think
we should divide ourselves radically
over the path we can disagree we can
debate the path but we all want to go
broadly in the same direction aoc
underscored that recently with their
comments second one is free college
that's not so radical we used to have it
before the massive under investment in
public education whether we get there in
one step or many steps and let's make
sure this includes not only college but
also training for people who don't want
to go to college in the book I quote
Richard Cordray ran for governor of Ohio
unfortunately he didn't win but I love
this line he said you shouldn't have to
go to college to join the middle class I
think we need to broaden that
conversation but that's got a lot of
possibility and lastly the green New
Deal which when you boil the green New
Deal down it is saying that we need
urgently to act on the climate and we
also urgently
to restructure the economy to make it
fairer and we need to do that partly to
redress losses that some groups might
suffer from taking bold action on the
climate I think these are all positives
that grow out of all of those negatives
so I guess I am NOT worried that a pure
anti Trump campaign will lack a positive
vision because I think you're hearing a
lot of positives in all these in the
mass of all these debates there were
actually a lot of proposals well the
book I want to make clear is not
proposing this vague idea of unity for
the sake of unity the way that we've
seen criticized over the last couple of
months as we've seen the Democratic
primary shift it's really a practical
and a sensible perspective on what it is
simply that needs to happen the book is
by EJ Dionne it is called code read how
progressives and moderates can unite to
save our country EJ so great having you
on I appreciate your time thank you so
much I hope we can do this again the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so we have a new bribery corruption
story about Donald Trump Donald Trump is
now being accused of having promised
WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange a
pardon if he were to publicly deny
Russia's involvement in the hacking of
the DNC back during the 2016 election
which of course would have been a lie
because we know that that is exactly the
way it went down
every aspect of this story is pure
corruption and it's down to the details
exactly what we would expect it even
involves congressman Russia the former
that's the nickname for the former
congressman dana rohrabacher who is also
tied up in this entire thing so this is
not Trump's Ukraine Biden corruption
extortion bribery this is not Trump
funneling money from taxpayers and
donors through the Secret Service into
his own hotels and resorts we've talked
about that this is not other emoluments
violations by Donald Trump we've talked
about that this is a new corruption
story about Donald Trump so it's widely
accepted that Russia hacked the DNC back
during the 2016 election Donald Trump
has been very eager to question or deny
that since day one because it fuels the
narrative that Russia preferred Trump
over Hillary Clinton which we of course
now know to be true as well Julian
Assange is the founder of WikiLeaks he
is now under arrest he's facing
extradition previously had been holed up
to avoid arrest in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London for years and years to
avoid that extradition
eventually he overstayed his welcome
there were allegations about hygiene and
all sorts of other stuff in any case at
some point the Ecuadorian embassy said
No Mas
so Julian Assange's lawyer now asserts
in court during a pre extradition
hearing that Donald Trump through
proxies offered Julian Assange a pardon
if he were to agree to help cover up the
truth of the Russia hack meaning Trump
wanted Assange to sow disinformation
seeking to distance Russia from the DNC
hack and this is a mind-blowing
allegation the person who allegedly
communicated the offer to Julian Assange
was none other than former Republican
congressman Dana Rohrabacher
a guy himself known for his sketchy
connections to Russia Rohrabacher went
to London in 2017 to make this offer it
is alleged Rohrabacher widely known as
congressman Russia and as Putin's
favorite congressman the claim was made
in court that quote mr. Rohrabacher
going to see mr. Assange and sang on
instructions of the president that he
was offering a pardon or some other way
out
if Assange said Russia had nothing to do
with the DNC leaks the White House was
asked about this allegation and they
issued a very carefully worded denial
check it out a Stephanie Grisham the
White House press secretary who we never
see cuz she doesn't do press briefings
said quote the president barely knows
Dana Rohrabacher other than he's an ex
congressman he's never spoken to him on
this subject or almost any subject it is
a complete fabrication and a total lie
this is probably another never-ending
hoax and total lie from the DNC notice
that the statement says Trump barely
knows Rohrabacher well you don't have to
know him at all to get him to
communicate a possible pardon to Julian
Assange the statement says Trump has
never spoken to Rohrabacher about this
of course any number of middlemen could
have passed along the message to
Rohrabacher and then they blame the DNC
completely without evidence which of
course has nothing to do with this as
far as we know this is an assertion that
was made in a British Court by the
lawyer of Julian Assange and there is
nothing to do with the DNC as far as we
currently have evidence this isn't the
first time that Rohrabacher
trip to London was asserted to be
connected to an Assange pardon
two months after this trip happened The
Wall Street Journal reported what
Rohrabacher was doing in that trip was
trying to arrange a deal for Donald
Trump to pardon Julian Assange so it's
not even the first time that that has
been suggested the White House confirmed
at the time that Rohrabacher had spoken
to Donald Trump's chief of staff John
Kelly about the plan
to free Julian Assange but it wasn't
clear who had personally spoken to whom
did Trump speak to Rohrabacher or not
but it doesn't really matter because you
don't need to have a direct conversation
for the assertion to be true The Daily
Beast says that in 2018 Rohrabacher told
the intercept that he was blocked from
discussing the plan with the president
because Kelley and others thought it
would look like collusion so case in
point when the White House says Trump
never spoke to Rohrabacher about it we
have a report from The Daily Beast that
says they were deliberately
communicating through others to avoid it
looking like they were colluding on this
so is this believable of course it is do
we have reason to doubt it well with any
of these stories we should apply a
healthy level of skepticism in this case
we have reports from two different news
agencies in the past combined now with
the assertions by Julian Assange his
lawyer and the fact that this is how
Donald Trump is known to work Trump has
implicitly suggested that people who
keep their mouths shut about him could
get a pardon calling them strong people
who don't crack like Paul Manafort you
might remember Trump has withheld aid to
Ukraine unless they smear Biden he got
caught and ultimately had to release the
aide this is how Donald Trump has always
done business as a real estate developer
in New York down to the details this is
how Trump operates and in the end we go
back to if there's nothing wrong if
there's nothing with Russia here why
again is there more of an effort
uncovered that was geared towards hiding
Russia's involvement in that DNC hack
and like I told you yesterday Trump and
pardons these are political tools that
he uses and he will keep using them to
his advantage if he is re-elected to a
second term that you can be sure of so
as you all know I'm voting for Bernie in
the Democratic primary this is not a
partisan story I will be voting for
Bernie this is not an attack on Bernie
I'm going to vote for Bernie in the
Massachusetts Democratic primary I am
NOT attacking
or supporting any candidate with this
story but the entire Bernie Bloomberg
heart health story that has been
developing over the last 48 hours is
really really bad and here's the the way
it's been going down both Michael
Bloomberg and Bernie Sanders are close
to 80 years old they both have heart had
heart issues Bernie Sanders had a heart
attack last year Michael Bloomberg had
one or two stents placed about 20-25
years ago they should both release their
full medical records period this doesn't
have anything to do with who's better on
health care or who's better on
stop-and-frisk
or who's more or less racially sensitive
this has nothing to do with that okay
Bernie said he'd release his full
records then he backtracked put out
three doctor's letters and says that's
all that we're going to put out there
are Bernie staffers attacking
Bloomberg's heart health with
misstatements and it's toxic and
terrible so let's start there Bernie's
national press secretary Briana Joy gray
yesterday on CNN listen to this she
likens the Bernie health records
requests to birtherism which is bonkers
and then incorrectly states that Michael
Bloomberg has had heart attacks I don't
think we will release any more medical
records I have those three letters from
the doctors the senator Sanders was
talking about there's there's nothing in
a mother and the doctor saying that he's
fit he had a heart attack yeah we heard
attack in the fall do you think the
American people deserve to know more
about his health going forward I think
the American people deserve to know
exactly as much as every other candidate
hasn't released in this race currently
and historically and what you're seeing
right now is really reminiscent of some
of the kind of smear kind of skepticism
campaigns that have been run against a
lot of different candidates in the past
I'm questioning where they're from
aspects of their their their lineage etc
etc and it's really telling given that
none of the same concern is being
demonstrated for Michael Bloomberg who's
the same age as Bernie Sanders who has
suffered heart attacks in the past and
what we're seeing is a kind of um so she
says Michael Bloomberg has suffered
heart attacks in the past plural and
that's not true Michael
berg has not had any heart attacks it's
just not true it doesn't mean
Bloomberg's the better candidate
Bloomberg's still imploded at
yesterday's debate
none of that changes but Bloomberg had a
stent put in for a blocked artery 20 or
25 years ago now Bernie's press
secretary later corrected and said she
misspoke after being called out saying
quote I misspoke when I said Bloomberg
had a heart attack rather he underwent
the same stent procedure as Bernie
Bernie released three detailed medical
reports in December just like the other
candidates I am finding this to be
pretty crazy
okay the when Trump says I released the
transcript he didn't he released you
know a piece of it when Brianna joy
graces Bernie released three medical
reports they are doctors letters which
Democrats previously widely said when
Trump released them they were not
sufficient we've just got to be
consistent guys okay Bernie promised his
full record and then backtracked he
asked it is a very reasonable ask given
Bernie's a age and given Bernie's recent
heart attack it is completely and
totally reasonable look up life
expectancy for white males born in the
United States Bloomberg has had stents
put in demanding the same of Michael
Bloomberg is perfectly reasonable
Peabody judge during the debate
yesterday said he'd be willing to
undergo a physical or whatever this is
not about Pete Buddha judge although we
should have the records from everybody
we just need transparency on this issue
I don't think it's like birtherism I
don't think it's a dirty trick I plan to
vote for Bernie in Massachusetts but he
promised it he's nearly 80 he had a
heart attack and he should release
actual full medical records not just
some doctor's letters Biden has had
brain surgery he's nearly 80 we should
know everything there is to know about
Biden's health situation there is no
question that cynical actors can
weaponize this health thing it's not a
gist to be concerned about this in
principle but we've got to be
responsible I guess I believe Brianna
joi grey misspoke although she's been
doing a lot of miss speaking lately I
don't know but this is starting to get
ugly on multiple sides it is not there's
nothing wrong with believing that
you should do what he promised to do
which he now says he's not going to do
he should do it michael bloomberg should
put out his records
we should get full disclosure from Joe
Biden and we actually may have close to
that from Joe Biden Joe Biden's put out
quite a bit just put out the records
guys that's all and then vote for
whoever you agree with most on the
issues for me it's Bernie it's very
simple
but I still want to see that full
medical record let's go to our voicemail
two one nine two david p is the
voicemail number Jimmy from Philly is
wondering why I didn't cover a
particular story about Bernie Sanders
take a listen to this David give me from
Philly yeah
why have we not seen you drop a video on
the women that took Bernie's mic once
again topless why have we not seen you
show how weak Bernie Sanders actually is
uh-huh I mean this man has that black
lives matter people grab his mic right
now it's well white college girls kitty
listen grab his mic what more do you
need to see David to figure out that you
voted for a little [ __ ] all right like
I understand yeah so listen first of all
the entire why don't you grab the mic
back thing is a double-edged sword
because if Bernie doesn't take the mic
back when the mic has been grabbed and I
don't think that the topless protesters
did that if you don't take the mic back
people like Jimmy from Philly say it's
bata behavior if you do grab the mic
back cynical actors will say that it was
almost a physical attack on women and
what is Bernie doing as a man taking the
microphone back so I actually understand
why Bernie just walks away when the
protesters come onstage
we just don't cover protests in this way
like Biden's been protested Bernie's
been Prost has it this is no what do you
want me to say about it okay yeah Bernie
was protested by topless protesters
what's the story that that's why we
haven't covered it in we've got a great
bonus show for you today I hope you will
join us there become a member
or a patron to get yourself instant
access
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]